all right well i think we might have
some other news in another state
uh it's now official fox news is calling
the virginia governor's race for
republican glenn younkin let's bring in
martha and brett
it has been a hard-fought long battle
here it is there's been a lot of polling
our polling last week finally showed us
that it looked like uh likely voters
were going to search for yunkan looks
like he closed strong bretton martha
what do you think finally got him over
the top
it is official the fox news decision
desk is now calling this race for glenn
younkin he will now be the governor
elect of virginia shannon and what is
amazing is that
you know it looked like this was going
to tip earlier in the night we had to
wait until some of those big places as
bill described them came in with all
their final votes but if you look at
where yunkan went
from the beginning
and he was not counted in in this race
at all dealing with a former governor
who had a democratic machine in a state
that joe biden won by 10 points he was
not well known he was way back in the
pack in fact he had to
work hard to win a primary and then
managed to figure out a way to campaign
on the issues that people in virginia
cared about and that is what won uh glen
younk in this race martha he turned this
tide really in the past
few weeks i would say within a month
that this really turned for glenn
younkin who is now the governor elect of
virginia and he is going to bring with
him a lot of republicans that will
change the way the commonwealth operates
yeah the site of glenn younkin's
campaign bus says a new kind of leader
and i think that the definition of glenn
younkin and how he pulled off this very
um upset win in virginia and how he
turned it just over the last several
weeks by
by really understanding where the people
of virginia were on this issue of
education and also you know this is
really a testament to the fact that
candidates matter the the person matters
he had almost no surrogates he had a
team
of people that would sort of cobble
together over the course of this while
he started to get some more momentum uh
the team came together but this was
always all about glenn younkin uh he's a
former rice university basketball player
he worked for the carlisle group harvard
business school graduate but he's a he's
a son of virginia grew up in virginia
beach uh for the most part and talked
about
his really positive message he kept
saying brett you know america is the
greatest country in the world you
weren't hearing that from the other side
but glenn young can said it every time
he went out there and i think he gave
people a reason to feel good and they
wanted to support him whether they were
independents or democrats in some cases
shannon as a businessman he had the
opportunity to play it like mitt romney
did was focus on his business career at
carlisle he didn't really do that he
focused really on issues and education
became an issue that lifted up this
campaign also he had going for him a
president a democratic president who was
falling in the polls and a number of key
misses by the biden administration and i
think that this race in particular is
going to send a message here in
washington d.c and i think we don't know
where this is going to go as far as how
it affects moderates up on capitol hill
how it affects these pieces of
legislation that are still stalled
because president obama biden can't get
it across the finish line i think we
have yet to see that and we have yet to
see where this new jersey race ends up
no matter what happens in new jersey the
message has been sent virginia is a
republican state now and it was 10
points to joe biden's favor just that
long a year and a half ago and and i
just want to point out this guy we've
heard young can say this quite a bit on
the campaign trail but just a reminder
of the sot that he has a lot of times he
says ten months ago our first internal
poll i had a two percent name idea with
a three percent margin of error he says
we've been focusing on the issues that
are most important to virginia
virginians in these kitchen table issues
and he really has listen there's a very
successful guy but he kind of became
known for wearing this fleece vest and
walking around and talking to parents
and talking about kids
and really trying to connect with people
um but you know you guys to hear him say
that he was pulling basically it could
have been at negative one percent based
on the first internal polls and and he's
not a politician we didn't know who he
was um so he has some commonalities with
president trump and that he was a
successful businessman wasn't a
political guy but very different in
their demeanor and their execution of
their campaigns
style message absolutely demeanor
absolutely he he's going to be a
candidate as i said who is a model for
republicans for the future but he's a
he's a very strong individual with a
very he's got a lot of energy he's like
6'4
so when he walks into the room he gets a
lot of attention but the way that he
navigated the issue of the former
president donald trump i think is
something that you're going to hear a
lot of discussion about because he he
embraced
the president's policies um i thought it
was very interesting the other night
when some when they were pushing this
whole the teleconference and was he
going to be part of it or wasn't he he
said uh you know i'm going to be
somewhere else that night but you know
our our folks are talking yeah so he was
always threading that needle in a way
and president trump was one of the first
to come out before we called the race uh
and and said you know congratulations to
him and but he also said he only won
because my base was motivated exactly
but in reality
he motivated people in the suburbs he
motivated independents he motivated some
democrats in virginia to cross over and
vote for him
that is something today donald trump
could not do in virginia at least as the
environment is currently and
so this is a unique candidate that
managed to walk between between those uh
minefields of political troubles you
know i think about president biden too
who we've said you know is on his way
back from scotland and he's going to
land and sort of see a new landscape and
you think about bill clinton back in
1994 sort of shifting towards you know
work to welfare programs and going
towards the middle that was after the
midterms when republicans under newt
gingrich had an enormous sweep but you
wonder if the biden administration sort
of tries to recalibrate before that
potentially happens to them and takes
the message that we're seeing tonight in
virginia and in new jersey as well i
think even regardless of what the final
outcome is in new jersey or whether he
stays the court hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else